good afternoon everyone it's mike and
i'm gonna get started in about 10 or 15
seconds here i'm just making sure my
microphone is working fine which it
appears to and making sure this is being
recorded because you know i did get a
lot of questions if this is going to be
recorded because you know this was sort
of a
a quick decision to have this training
today on sunday you know i thought that
you know with the holiday weekend i know
a lot of users are excited to get the
new version i'll be sending out the link
if you're an existing user of order
flows trader so if you have order flows
trader 3.0 i'll be sending you out the
link to get the
download the new version order flows
trader 5
as well as the user guide so
it's
exciting i think it's exciting um you
know because some of you have been
emailing me back and forth over the last
about year you know saying hey mike can
we get this uh added in there you know
this is how i like to look at order flow
and you know for some of you it can be
brand new for others it could be you
know like oh you know
now i all make sense to me in the market
so without further ado
let's get started i'm going to try and
keep this relatively quick today you
know an hour sometimes you know i do
these presentations and they tend to run
for
over an hour but you know again it's
sunday it's sunday afternoon and you
know it's a holiday weekend so
try and keep it
short and sweet
okay so
the before i get started you know brief
disclaimer we all we're all adults here
right we all understand that trading
involves risk
now order flows trader has undergone
eight upgrades in this new version right
this is the order flows trader five
people say well what about version four
you know if you're asian or you ever
spend time in asia particularly china
you understand that the number four is
um
a very unlucky number it sounds like the
word death in chinese so we just sort of
skipped over you know just like in in
the u.s you know
building skipped the number
13 right on the floor you go in the
elevator goes 12 14. um that's why it's
version 5. so you didn't miss anything
out in version 4 because there was no
version 4.
we just jumped to uh version 5. and i
feel that you're going to find that
these upgrades are going to help your
analysis
and help you understand market structure
better okay
now
you'll notice some of these are
enhancements right there are new tools
as well as enhancements to existing ones
now some of these enhancements are quite
intensive in the coding part because if
you get one little thing wrong it's
going to drag your system down it's
going to make your system slow so we
really wanted to
you know keep it efficient and keep it
smooth and running the software you know
as efficiently as possible okay so
the first upgrade that i'm going to talk
about is a new tool okay and this is
called buying and selling tails in my
course order flow alchemy we call this
the double o trade okay if you haven't
got the order flow alchemy course you
know it's a great course there's there's
a few setups in there that you know a
lot of traders have been telling me hey
you know this is
very helpful to my trading and basically
a double o trade is as a buying tale or
a selling tail and when a buying tale
appears it's a sign of passive sellers
disappearing on a push down
so as a result of the disappearance of
those passive sellers on the way down
price often quickly snaps back reverses
back it leaves a buying tail okay the
selling tail is the opposite right a
market has been
rallying
but you don't have the passive buyers
coming in okay
to keep the move going up you know
sometimes it could just be a stop
getting triggered okay and basically you
know those people that are short down
there or long up at the high um you know
they're caught off sides
okay and the market often sees a quick
rebound
coming off of it now
when you have a lack of support of
buying and a move up right what do you
think the market's going to do well it's
going to come off right and that's what
tails are so
with the buying and selling tail
tool
you also have the ability to draw out
the zone
until tested or fixed
and i'm going to talk about you know
these different zones a little bit later
but uh briefly
you know
i look for longs until tests
until the zones get tested again okay so
it's going to help you keep you on the
right side you know it's best to just
look at a chart okay let's pull up a
chart now this is the e-minis okay
we're trying to keep it
relatively plain
e-mini's today i as i was sort of
thinking through today's presentation i
realized you know what i should also do
a presentation on
strategies using these different tools
because it's one thing to show you the
tool but if you don't really understand
how to use it then you're probably not
going to get the most out of it and
especially when you're trading with you
know these new zones that are coming out
you know until tested okay so for ex
this is it right here now
in the indicator settings you know
everything is in alphabetical order
right except for the license that starts
up at the top it's always up at the top
um
so buying and selling tails at the top
and you know it'll be dark blue for
bullish ones dark red for
bearish ones
and you can see you could draw it out
fix the fixed zone and say you just want
it highlighted in the bar
or if you want it until tested okay if
you just want it fixed
you change that to fixed and you just
put out how many um
bars out you want to do it but you know
until tested is nice now
you do have the ability to
look for swing highs and swing lows as
well as check eva right eva
is
under the value area it's one of the
settings in the value area right and
we've found that
when you have a tail and it occurs in an
eba it's a very high percentage trade so
for example
here is in this case this is e-minis
this is on friday
let me get the crosshairs here
okay here you have the
buying sorry
you have the uh selling tail up here
right this is bearish right so you have
the aggressive buying going up in there
now this is not a inverse imbalance
right you just see it's in balance at
the top you're usually going to have an
imbalance in a tail because
it's zero zero right it's a double zero
trade and the price action came down and
people say well you know that's so easy
but so many people miss it and in this
case this is one with an eva i have
check eva off here
i just pull up the indicator again
yeah it's disabled and again if you want
to see it in every bar you would check
higher high or lower low right but i
have it just looking for swing highs and
swing lows and how you would trade it is
you know once it leaves that tail up
there market starts trading down in this
case this is a selling tail right you
can see the market trading down you know
as soon as the market starts breaking
you know after the bar closes it starts
breaking down that's where you get short
and look at this trade right people say
well it's so easy double zero i don't
need an indicator for that yeah well
you're gonna stare at your screen all
day and and look for it i mean this was
just this slam dunk trade now this is
one with an eva
but again you know it's coming in around
the 70 you know getting short i don't
know 74 and a half 75 trades all the way
down to the low of the day you know now
some days it's it's not as dramatic as
as that let's take a look if there's any
others
on this friday
this is just friday okay again i'm
trying to keep everything in the e-minis
but you know it would be the same thing
if you're looking at crude oil
uh you know
mini dao nasdaq
etc okay so you know
honestly in the e minis you don't get a
ton of them because there's just so much
volume especially during the day
but
for those that are like oh you know
that's that's take a look at this i'll
show you something here
um
[Music]
what day was it well this is right on
the cash show beyond the cash open you
always got to be careful here's one
right on the buy then here's a cell came
off a little bit tested it up there
look at this this was on the 17th the
low of the day right and you got the
bullish eva as well
all right you see that it made a nice
move up there right it held it tested
those areas
now again you know as i was thinking
through this presentation i realized you
know not a lot of people understand how
to trade zones you know it's one thing i
see a lot of videos out there you know
people
they draw their zones out but they don't
really get into how to trade them and
there's different ways to approach them
right because when the markets come back
to a level it can either hold it
or it can blow right through it
and you know when it holds it it's going
to stop and reverse or it can just blow
right through and certain different
types of levels mean different things in
the market so that's why i think it
might be beneficial for me to do another
training but i'll probably just record
it and send it out to you on how to use
the zones
but i mean
you know the low of the day
you're getting the buying tail all right
4401 and a half you know it rallies all
the way up in
you know 20s get another buying tail
right here right it keeps rallying up
right it keeps you know see it comes
down and tests it right there and
finally it breaks through
and
you know in more volatile markets you
know again i'll diverge here but if you
were uh you know
let me just ruin mini dao
okay
if you were to
look at uh
you know mini dao okay markets that are
more volatile that have more price
movement with less volume okay
you're going to see a bit more of them
right because you got a lot of zeros
happening in in the bars especially you
know overnight or
um you know during the day you get a lot
of these knee jerk reactions okay so
the filter that we added
is the eva right the expanded volume
it's value area rather so
if you were to add that
it can take out
filter out some of the trades that don't
have you know the the extra confirmation
in the order flow to
you know to give it right so you know
you get this beautiful trade here
right you got a nice short coming in
here and it's just
beautiful beautiful on the way down you
know people say well that's the same one
from the other day what about um you
know overnight was there anything
overnight
there one it's trailing back i don't
know how far back that went
the day before or overnight right seven
o'clock
at night 7 50 rather you know just for
eight o'clock
you know people trade at night right and
you got a nice trade here and even if
you're just holding it for five minutes
you're talking a move from you know the
70s
all the way up above you know 400
okay
but there's there's a lot of these
trades to be had right different markets
if you could filter out
some of them you know with the filter on
obviously you're going to get less
trades because now it's just you know
it's looking for bars that have eva so
you can see during the day
you know there was one here
um had a nice move up people say well it
came down well
you know
i mean peckers can't be choosers it's a
move from 800 up to 850
basically you know good 25 picks right
there
you know that's
that's an extra tool that you could add
to your toolbox again
if you're going to use the eva as a
filter i would suggest you use it on the
more volatile markets like
mini dial gold maybe
definitely mnq and nq you know more
markets that are more volatile
okay so
the
next
upgrade i want to talk about
is the prominent point of controls okay
so primary point controls have existed
in the order flows trader software
but one of the criteria that originally
we had was it had to appear at swing
highs and swing lows
and you know sometimes it'd be like you
know you would see these moves happen
and it would just be like
you know that
looks and smells like a prominent point
of control but just not a swing high or
swing low you know and so as a result we
would skip them and so what we did we
made it so that you can
use the prominent point of control
anywhere okay as opposed to just swing
highs or swing lows so
if because what we noticed is
a lot of times prominent point of
controls would come in just after
swing higher swing low has been made but
since we had that one
pretty rigid constraint that had to be a
swing higher swing low
then it
just wouldn't show okay and as a result
those trades wouldn't be taken so
the
we had to make an adjustment
to look for it anywhere okay so
uh let's take a look at a chart here
um stick with the e-minis right so
here's your
swing low
okay
and market starts moving up all right
and we've got a prominent point of
control right here
okay it's a nice prominent point of
control
right before the market popped now here
we have very bullish information right
we have a slingshot poc which is bullish
and we have a bullish value area right
bullish eba now where would you rather
be taking this trade right off this
prominent point of control
which normally in the past would not
show up as a prominent point of control
because it would only be looking
swing highs or swing lows right and this
is not a swing low
then
follow up with the bush so you're
getting
long you know somewhere after this bar
closes but now you could be getting long
in this bar
so you know you're getting in
a little bit early right so you could
see these things these
moves happening earlier
okay as as trends are developing in the
market right you want to take advantage
of them as soon as possible right and
you know that was sort of you know why
while
the primary point of control
originally is still strong
you know this just gives you an extra
option now how would you do that is
under the settings you'd go
to the prominent point of control
okay again it's all alphabetical so
prominent point control so you can see
here
it's zero normally you would have a
setting of three
or you know five
you know or five you know you'd have
different settings too look for it
anywhere you just set it to zero
okay that was just the easiest way to do
it is to set it to zero
and then you'd click apply
and it's already set to zero i just
clicked apply
but
that's how you do it okay so
you know that was an enhancement right i
said these were some new tools and
enhancements right
this is an enhancement to an existing
tool so you're taking the tool and
making it better okay now
the
next
four upgrades okay our
zone drawing abilities okay so they deal
with market exhaustion order flow
sequencing inverse and balance and value
areas now each of these are important
for their own reason now honestly i do
not suggest that you draw out zones
you know until tested
on all of them at once
because again you know each market
trades differently and
you know sometimes you may not want to
use
um
depending on the market right because i
said if if you're
you can draw them out
but if you're trading you know more
volatile markets right maybe you're
going to be looking more for inverse
imbalances right it's like say nasdaq or
ym okay if you're trading more thicker
markets you'll be looking at the value
areas more i mean that's not to say that
you can't look at value areas in the
wheat
but
depending on the type of chart it's
going to be
not as
you know if you look at a one minute
wheat chart okay
it only moves
four ticks right you're gonna have a
value area that could be drawn out but
you know the value is only 50 cents two
ticks right whereas if you're trading
say a
e-mini and you're looking at the value
area
and you draw that out you know you're
going to have a nice solid value area on
a one-minute chart so again it depends
on the markets that you're looking at
you could add them all up on there but
you know just be aware of what you're
looking at right some we tend to keep
the colors the same so you may need to
adjust the colors a little bit but i'll
show you that in a second so
you know the last thing you want to do
basically is end up with a lot of zones
on your screen and then you're just back
to square one
um
so let's go back
to
where am i we'll start with the market
exhaustion okay so for example
you see these zones being drawn out
these are zones of market exhaustion all
right and what's the market exhaustion
here exhaustion prints okay so you have
your choice of fixed before it was just
fixed
and you draw your level you know the
single just in the bar itself or
you know if you wanted to draw five
price levels 10 price levels now this is
something that i've been getting emails
since
the original order flows trader software
started in in 2015 um because traders
it's fine you know certain marketing
many
so many different traders i've
had the fortune to work with over the
years especially you know releasing the
older illustrator software
and seeing what's important to different
people and this is something people have
been hounding me for i'm like hey i'll
get to it i'll get to it um
and then
you know because honestly you know
sometimes you're drawing out a lot of
zones again it puts a lot of strain on
the pc and then that's the last thing we
want to do
but i'm going to show you
in some markets you know
behave differently okay so this is
e-mini's okay so let's start here
okay and again i have exhaustion print
in here exhaustion print here now it's
being drawn out until tested right
here's an exhaustion print being drawn
out until tested it tested it here these
haven't been tested yet
okay the market rallied up hit it all
right came
you know i say came back down but you
know i came up with is that 64 and a
quarter you know got as low as you know
62 61 and a quarter
again just sort of hanging around there
there's another one tested you know this
one got through these are areas
that need to be repaired that's why you
often see the market come back to them
and there's different ways to trade that
right you can trade it
the market to react personally in most
markets i'm looking for them to be
repaired in other markets i'm looking
for them to be tested and when i say
other markets i mean very liquid markets
right treasuries um
you know i have a group of treasury
traders
10 years
all they key on there are they're just
looking for these
exhaustion prints right because
markets like 10 years trade tons and
tons of volume right you could have 10
000 contracts trade on the bid and 10
000 trade at the offer and mark's not
going anywhere then you just see 10
contracts trade all right then the
markets are screaming in the direction
that's their go-to trade and and having
things like this a lot of times you'll
see in in market like treasuries it just
comes right back up to that area of the
exhaustion and then comes off again
there's certain strategies as well to
trade this i don't have it on this chart
because this is e-minis you know some
people say well this is ugly right you
see it's just all these zones right well
again if you're this is literally to the
tick okay
this one failed all right
and this one
failed i guess you could say it failed
got through it by two ticks this one got
through it by two ticks imagine you know
this price level right you have a chance
to come back up to this level repair it
and come off okay you have a limit
fifth uh
57 and a half sell one
right you have a stop
a couple ticks higher all right i'm
going to show you and other examples
where you could
literally the market comes right to that
level right to the tick and reacts
right here's another level came one tick
through it right if you just got a two
tick stop
one tick stop all right this one you two
ticks
okay you get stopped out your two ticks
stop okay you don't get stopped out so
you have you know a loss here or lost
here
lost here here right you're buying it at
50 it rallies all the way back up to 55.
all right you're risking
one or two ticks if you're risking you
know two ticks here two ticks there
maybe you're getting stopped out maybe a
little bit wider on your stops there's
different ways to trade it okay
because you know you're always looking
for these areas to come back so i mean
if you're getting five
points
and you're risking you know one or two
ticks you can have a lot of losers right
again i don't recommend that for
everybody you know i recommend that for
people that trade you know another way
people trade zones is they're looking
for the zone to get blown through right
the market to repair it when you
understand market repairs itself
it finds those areas of weak order flow
comes back and repairs it and oftentimes
keeps moving so imagine you just have a
buy stop
in here okay again you buy stop with the
stop couple ticks below
it goes up
right you get a nice move up higher
there's so many different ways to trade
that's why i have to do a strategy video
on this to
help everyone understand it now again if
you're looking at a market like say
treasuries i got treasuries on here i'm
sure i do
so i have my glasses on so it's a little
hard for me to read the screen as close
let me just pull it up now you know on
treasuries you're not going to use a
one-minute chart you're going to use
ideally you need something with to take
into account the price range okay so
um you know maybe you're going to use a
four range chart or you could use a
volume based chart or a tick based chart
it's up to you
how you want to use it but you can see
these areas right look at that the three
came right to it you could just put a
bid in here
hopefully you can get filled
right and you can see how these these
areas just come right back right look at
this this was an area from
you know here's an area right below the
low of the day
within a tick here okay didn't it happen
there's another zone here
again these two zones got within a tick
there's different ways to trade it i'm
not saying you have to trade it right at
the tick i know again you know you can
put your limit just before it depending
on the market right understand the
market that you're trading okay and
again when you see
an exhaustion print in the market
right and then you start seeing the tail
get bigger
you know the direction you want to be on
right you you want to be short until it
starts testing those areas
okay so i got exhaustion print here
great i get short
another exhaustion print great i know
the market's going in my direction stay
short stay short until where well i
don't have another exhaustion
uh print coming in until way down here
so you know i know i got some room i
know i could give this trade
some you know
a
area to grow to go to just as is in here
right look at this
okay exhaustion print exhaustion print
exhaustion print okay you had one here
okay you came back up and just sort of
spent some time around here it's been
about 20 minutes trading around here it
didn't react but i know i've got
exhaustion down here exhaustion down
here it's leaving these
um
zones being drawn out right then i get
another one here great get long if
you're not already long you should
already be long in here
then you see the exhaustion print come
in here long again right and just stay
stay with it right it's going to help
keep you on the right side of the market
you know so that was the you know that's
10 years so
again
when you're dealing with market
exhaustion in high volume markets
watch for those areas to be retested
i mean in every market you should
actually look for them be tested but in
specific markets again not everyone's
interested in training 10 years it's
like watching paint dry sometimes
although now with all the talk of
interest rates at least it's got some
movement but
you know in
very high volume markets you know
they're often retested in other markets
you're looking for them to be repaired
but it's a level that can give you a
very tight
stop
now order flow sequencing right we did
the same thing okay now again you know
you have all these zones being drawn out
you don't want to be just drawing out
zones willy-nilly right you want to be
understanding why they're drunk and
honestly i see a lot of people draw
zones out on their charts i see these
14 year old kids on youtube posted
videos heck man some of these kids got
more subscribers than me and it's just
like
i don't get it but
they just throw up these magical zones
on there without any rhyme or reason but
order flow gives you
solid reasoning in order for sequencing
right if you understand what order flow
sequencing is it's the result of resting
liquidity
in the order book
being taken out okay more importantly um
strong liquidity
you know stacked liquidity an offer with
next offers more volume next offers more
volume next offer is more volume
okay and
as we know markets like to retest these
previous areas of liquidity sometimes
they hold sometimes they fail but you
know when they hold they often hold to
the very tick
okay so you can have those
tight stops you know those one to four
tick stops with
10 to 20
and more
tick targets
okay
so let's take a look at it um
this is my 10-year chart here let's go
back to e-mini chart
again under the indicator
you would find
order flow sequencing okay we're over
here order flow sequencing scroll down
order flow sequencing okay it's enabled
until tested right okay so that's what i
want to see until tested
okay so
you see right here this is a
oracle sequencing here so i know i had
resting liquidity in the book and again
it's coming in an area that you had a
lot of trading going on and it's kind of
hidden that's where looking at the order
flow is going to come in handy
and using some software that reads the
order flow for you is
going to help you okay
and
if i had you know here's sequencing here
here's sequencing here sequencing here
sequencing here what's the difference
right the next bar it came in and it
filled that area okay fine filled that
area filled that area in here by
attack filled it obviously we're trading
back and forth but look at this one hmm
what happened you had the sequencing the
market sold off
now it's got to come back to
repair it
okay and it came back
literally right to that zone you know
you just you have an offer in here
where you know you just put it inside
the zone in here at you know 64. maybe
you want to go one tick below it 63 and
a half
because a nice little you know where's
your stop just on the other side you
know you go 65
you're putting a limit in at 64. stop at
65.
the market trades down i don't want to
talk about you know how it trade all the
way down here but
you know 64.
you know down below 60 that's a nice
trade
right
now again you can see here how it came
down right through that tick and then
rallied back up now it rallied back up
to where right an area where you had a
bearish prominent point of control so
again it's not you have these levels
okay
but you gotta start putting the pieces
together right it's not just well i i
had a zone here
and it reacted but then it came off and
it failed well you know as a trader you
should be analyzing what's happening in
the market i know the market's selling
off i know i've got um
a
selling tail up here okay i know i got
the bearish prominent point of control
here i know i got the bearish eva here
so i know i'm selling off okay already
where's my target going to be it's going
to come down here to 71-ish
right that's the top of this zone from
earlier it's being drawn out it tests it
71 rallies back all the way up you know
the 77 i'm not saying you'd buy it here
at 71 and sell it at 77.
you know if you had a bid in here 71 and
a quarter you know even 71. okay maybe
you got lucky he had something in
let's click five points
almost in the same bar because you know
this bar opened up traded down we even
closed up at 76 and the quarter
boom
very fast trade five points
okay and then bearish order flow comes
in here
okay
and the markets are selling off right
then we get through that area just like
here people say well you had one here
and the market failed well yeah okay it
sold off
okay now i'm going to watch you know if
i have a limit in here
well okay i got stopped out fine you
know but what happened as i got stopped
out i know i had some bullish order full
sequencing coming in here so again i'm
not all too surprised to see it get
stopped out
so that's how you would use the you know
again i can go more deeper into it but
again
each of these i could literally do an
hour on i'd want to keep everyone on
here for an hour today
now the
next one again you know i suppose
first i was going to talk about the
value area but i'll come back to that
one i'll talk about the
inverse and balance
zones okay again until tested now this
was one that we had a lot of trouble
with i'll admit because
it was
being linked because you know when
you're dealing with imbalance in versus
what's
causing it right what's the sign of
trapped traders okay now sometimes these
levels are never tested again in the
same same day other times they're tested
very quick
and
there are areas of previous attempts at
breakouts
and you know if you've ever done any
studies on breakouts you know it's
always fascinating to see what happens
when the market comes back to that level
you know there's i know traders that
have strategies that they
have a second chance strategy that a
very high percentage is basically the
same trade but it's coming back down to
that level now we have an area where
traders we're interested in and the
market's coming back to that level
okay basically these are failed breakout
trades sometimes these are great go with
trades right you may imagine right this
is nasdaq right this is 30 seconds or so
mnq so 30 second chart
okay now granted in balance reversals if
you're
have used them on the order flows trader
software you understand that
they happen more in more volatile
markets
mnq nq a certain extent nasdaq um
very rarely see them in markets like uh
e-minis definitely not treasuries um
you know you see them off and on in
gold crude
in the more liquid times you tend to see
them
but you know markets that
are going you know they got high
volatility during the trading day that's
where imbalance reversals appear more
okay so
nasdaq is 7q rather
you can see a lot of them right whether
you're using a 30 second chart a 20
range chart a one minute chart you tend
to see a lot and again there's different
ways to trade these right i know i had a
failed breakout here market started
going up
it starts coming down
okay i had a failed breakout
we're going to make a second attempt at
it right we had a first attempt here
obviously marketing and second attempt
here third attempt right you know who
knows maybe there's a support level in
here that
you know some advisory service put out
or whatever
okay well i know i had people
interested in this area before and
enough to
leave that inverse imbalance there okay
well i just put a stop in here right
just put a stop in
right in here
right in the middle of the zone right or
you put it one tick below right with a
cell stop in here and then let your i
stop to get out right
that's a nice quick
trade to take now again it's
you know this one got filled really
quick this one got refilled really quick
i well this is a stacking bounce you're
looking for the
dark colors now with an inverse and
balance okay so i'll just take you
through the settings here
um scroll down here
it's under volume and balance is right
here until tested okay
used to be fixed now we've added until
tested okay now you could choose to
display the stacked imbalance as well
until tested
but the color right blue and red you'll
notice the opacity is 120. that's why
the color is so strong here as opposed
to
the normal stacked imbalance like this
is a green this is a
light coral
okay so let me see here there's
any others right here it was a stack
sorry an inverse imbalance
short from before right
when you see an inverse imbalance expect
the market to immediately trade in that
direction okay that's your sign to get
short right here
okay now
you take that trade
you get short
take your profit whatever it starts
coming back up
you know i had this area where earlier i
had that inverse imbalance right i had
traders that were trapped in the market
they were looking for a breakout for the
market to go higher now we're coming
back
okay
how to trade it let me just throw a
little buy stop in here
it gets filled take profit up here
if not your cell stop is just
you know five ticks away
okay sometimes you can get stopped out
sometimes you get a 10 or 15 point
winner you're going to lose
you know
four five six ticks on your stopped out
but you're making
you know
20 30 40 50 ticks on the upside right on
your take profit
right because why because this was an
area psychologically earlier people were
interested in buying for whatever reason
right but they got stuck they got
trapped now the market reacted
now i'm not saying that you know
this whatever this is 70 contracts up
here caused this move down because 70
contracts traders were trapped no they
had this is 10 36 you know they had 20
minutes 10 minutes to get out
so it's not like the 70 contracts is
causing the market things changed in the
market it caused the sell-off to happen
market sold off
but now that it's coming back conditions
have changed this time now that we're
making that second run up
conditions have changed and you're
starting to see as you're getting closer
you're starting to see the bullish order
flow come in here bullish prominent uh
sorry bullish slingshot poc bullish eba
you're starting to see the buying
imbalances come in the sequencing come
in
and you're like oh you know what i got
this level right here
right
that you're finally getting that little
push through and boom it just pops from
up to where
up the double o even a little bit higher
in the next
bar now that's the inverse imbalance now
the the next three that i'll talk about
times at 130.
okay let's go back here for a second
right because
so i've covered buying selling tails
the primary point control anywhere
the
enhanced
exhaustion prince exact enhanced order
flow sequencing enhanced inverse and
balance now i'm going to talk about
enhanced value area okay and so we're
going to lump i'll start out with the
enhanced value area and then the next
two um tick aggregation and shorten big
numbers now the reason why i sort of
want to keep it a little bit separate
because i'm
going to
jump a little bit into
uh equities as well okay um and if i get
a chance i'll pull up some cryptocharts
now value areas right valuers are very
important okay now this was a big one
that i wanted to have originally done
a while back and
you know
value area is something
that you know if you ever studied market
profile you understand what the value
area is and it's important so i'm not
going to get into the details of that
but now we can see those sort of those
virgin value areas right that's the
whole
what you want to look for just you know
when you think of until tested okay
you know with market exhaustion with all
the sequencing and bounce
is you're looking for those virgin
areas to come for the market to react to
now when you're dealing with value and
value areas value represents volume
in a crude sense okay
oftentimes value areas when you're
looking at it on a bar by bar basis
right
are traded into in the next bar
okay but there are times where they're
not traded into in the next bar or the
next bar or the next bar not until later
and these areas represent great buying
or selling opportunities
and
you know you know you understand markets
move in search of value right that's
if you've ever
again studied
market profile
you know the whole
market auction
auction market theory amt deals with
markets looking for value right and then
you know there's people that's all they
believe
and you know that that's what they trade
now one of the
i'll say drawbacks but you know one of
the constraints when you're dealing with
things like market profile or even to a
certain extent volume profile
is that
most people look at it on a
daily basis right they're they're
looking at the daily profile
okay i mean you can but there's a lot of
other trading going on right so
sometimes
you know if you put in a value area
and the market starts moving away from
it the rest of the day well you know
that value area
you know is you're not going to get much
use out of it because the market's
already moved away from it
and it's not going to give you any more
training opportunities but when you're
looking at on a intraday basis you know
on a minute basis now you could look on
a minute-based chart on a
five-minute chart um you know even range
based charts tick based charts
volume-based charts it's fascinating how
often times these levels hold because
the market is looking for value
where it can test it
or trade back into the
value or it can reject the value so
let's take a look here at the charts so
um
well
what do i got i think i got a mini chart
here is this
make sure i got the right chart
settings set up
i i sort of went through these to make
sure that these were set up
so i could show you each one now
this setting is a little bit different
okay
so
you can see here right it's turned off
okay it's this fixed okay
if you change it to until tested
what you have to do now this is
important because the only one you have
to do it on is
the value area box size you got to make
a you gotta change that value from zero
if it's zero it'll just show it in the
bar
but for this one you have to change it
to and like two or above right so that
it's going to draw it out at least you
know two
bars and you just click
apply
and
click
okay
now
this is a great tool right if you're
using
you know one minute a five minute chart
sometimes people say you know i like to
use order flow but i use a five minute
chart or a little bit longer chart and
you know a lot of what i teach with
order flow is really meant for shorter
time frames but
you could use the value areas on the 15
minute charts you could use them on
five-minute charts you can use them on
stocks look at this this is apple
okay this was on
friday
right this is your value area here
okay
i actually have the value areas itself i
have the
indicator turned on but
special value area is being drawn
turned off on this chart for some reason
set to transparent
because
if you're looking at this chart
right you see how the market came right
back up to this level came back off well
what was so special about this level up
here
that was the previous value area you
know that was untouched before
right the the virgin value area
right then came back here tested this
value it got through it came back into
that value area right mark it's always
looking to test value areas
got another value area here got right up
into it within a tick came back off to
where the value area here so you know
sometimes a lot of traders wonder well
why does the market stop up here
well
look to the left to the left to the left
this beyonce says
um that's where that value area was
before right it it tracks it right mark
is looking for the value right created a
lot of volume in here
all right now let's come back to an area
where it traded a lot of volume
oftentimes right if i had the
let me just
turn on the value areas here because you
can't see them i disabled the value
areas on each individual bar if i were
to turn on the value areas
transparent
i don't know what color it was uh where
am i was black
i think it's
black i got this one i should change
that to gray
let's give it a second to come back up
but yeah while waiting for that you know
let's take a look here right this is
e-mini's again you know
this is the market closed on friday but
you can see why you know market sold off
okay this is after the close right it
was
very quick screenshot right sold off
came right back up why did it stop at
this tick well that's the value area low
here
all right let's just hold off again
okay here's another value area untouched
right came off right back up to this
level sold off again
here it's another one right came
untouched came right back up into that
area sold off a bit and here's a small
one again you know those are just those
little areas right there you know this
is one was done right on the on the
clothes at one minute after the close
there's one here there's one here right
mark it went up came back down right
into that area
and then bounced back up to where where
they had that value area from earlier
right and again you know you can see
right the value area here right
here's one here right there's one here
you see the market went up
here it tested it right here
okay up up down right in here tested it
shot back up now he's throwing a bid
here somewhere
right here's another one right here
throwing a bid here right market trailed
right back up into this area here now
this one got through it but it stopped
at this at the second one here
now
there's different ways to trade these as
well you know obviously you could look
for the retest and the market to come
back up there
and then react to it now
again there's there's a thing we call
cascading um
when you're dealing with things like
value areas right and
you don't see it a lot in e-minis
because you know e-mini's is a market
that trades a lot of volume but when you
start seeing
you know one two three
you know in a row like that you know
obviously it's a sign of a market
trending down when you're leaving a lot
of
open value areas
you know it can
um it's a sign of you know a trending
market now these are stacked and
balanced that's a stacked imbalance
this one at 44. i don't think it came
back down on friday
did here tested it right here
again from 46
tested the high of this zone
you know up there but uh
you know
this one is gray you know normally it
would be red or green
it's gray if it's a uh doji candle or
open closed at the same price
but when you start seeing something like
cascading where if you had you know one
two three
in a row you know that's your sign to
you know
be short okay again you want to be on
the right side of the market because
when the market is putting in um
virgin value
areas in a row right that's where you
want to be going in that direction so
here's back to the apple chart right and
you've got one here one here
so you can see this is the value area
here right this is the value area here
this is the value area there
you know let's go back a bit right you
got this big value area here
okay
came right down to that area right you
got the value area here
right
notice
what happened
okay
came right down to that area rallied up
to the next one
right
here's another one right here
now is he going to ask why are some
green why are some blue the normal
coloring it would be green it's blue or
dark red if it's a eva right this is an
eva here which is bullish by itself
this is a
dark red one as opposed to these lighter
red colors here
i mean look at this right one two three
it's already cascading down okay
and oftentimes when you see it cascading
down like this when it starts repairing
them it often just marches right through
it to the upper one
okay and this one it got to one two so
i'm not surprised to see it get through
here or here
didn't get it through this one
but you can see just leaving it leaving
it leaving it all right then it came
down
then it changed right this is your low
of the day starts going back up
okay comes right back into the
zone right in here
right you know you're just throwing a
bid in here somewhere near the upper end
of it because you're looking for the
market to come back in and test it and
you don't have to test it you know and
test it in the midpoints you know
sometimes you'll get filled sometimes
not
or you can test it up on the upper end
or somewhere up in here
okay
so you can see how the markets you know
just tend to react now you know another
question i i got
from a tester was should you carry them
over from previous day levels we do draw
them out
um
yes it depends okay if it's a market
that trades 24 hours a day like
futures do yeah i'd be interested in
doing it but you know on stocks
i i think you got to be a bit careful
um in drawing them out
over
days
on end
okay
so you could you just see how the
markets often will stop within those
zones
stop within those zones right you're
just looking for those areas to trade
around right
ideally you know you want it to be more
than one bar out right here's just got
one bar that came right back into it you
know you want to get some space in
between the zones rather than just one
one one you know ideally
you know you want to get at least
two or three bars where it's drawn out
now again since i'm on apple right now
that's going to take me on the next
couple of
changes here okay so
on
tick aggregation okay now this is
something that that somebody has asked
me recently to do and we we created the
tick aggregation
um because of crypto okay and
you know cryptos trade in
satoshi's basically so you could buy you
know you know you don't buy one bitcoin
you buy whatever amount in
fiat currency or you say uh buy twenty
dollars worth of bitcoin
and you know it's going to be like 0.000
of a bitcoin you know something like
that and
the exchanges
will register it you know as a trade you
know at 39.99999
and
while doing this i'll switch to
well
i'll go to coinbase in a second but
because you can use this also in nasdaq
right so if you're trading nasdaq
so for example right i had an it's an
mnq chart okay
now
i have a 30 second chart why it's
because the market's so darn volatile
right you can see this bar right here
right 30 seconds range of 87 and a
quarter
all the way up to 82 and a half so
you know
that's a big range right if i'm looking
at a one minute chart
basically it's these two bars put
together you know all the way up to six
and a half so you know 20 point range in
a minute
and that's on a slow day right there's
some bars that are just you know
some days you know some bars are just
off the chart
so what you can do
you go to
the indicator setting
okay
and you scroll down it is under
where are we here
it's under the ladder contents
okay
here tick aggregation is set to zero
so you know i can set it to four okay
since
nasdaq trades in in quarters you know 71
71 and a quarter
um
you know or i can change it to eight
that would be like two ticks there are
two points rather
click apply the next one i'll talk about
is shorten big numbers okay
but for now i'll stick with tick
aggregation
and
this way if again i have this set for a
30 second chart
i'll bump it up to a one minute chart
now it's going to take a while because
it's got to go aggregate these ticks now
this is not something you'd want to do
during the course of training you
already have this set up right when you
open your charts every trading day
you should have your charts set up the
way you like to look at them
okay rather than jumping around changing
your charts
that's not what you want to do right you
should have a set of charts like for me
i've got i use tabs all right i have all
these tabs open
on my screen
on my trading platform so i can see them
you know as they're coming in now for
example all right apple right
like this is a stock right so it trades
in
one
one cent right
170.13 170.14
15. if
you know there's some stocks right if
you get involved in in some stocks i
don't know it's a good uh
stock i don't follow a lot of different
stocks
um you know but apple is one that
follows order flow beautifully um it
just follows beautifully you know oh i
should have done tesla
done
amazon but i think tesla's trades
similar right see all these areas in
here where you've got no trades
right big spaces in in the gaps in the
training it's just zeros
okay
basically from was that 12 up to 32.
you know it really makes understanding
you know reading the order flow a bit
harder so you know what you would do
you're going to aggregate these ticks
right so instead of doing it in one cent
increments
right because basically it's trying to
read it like this right trying to read
um you know 31 32 33 34 well there's
nothing going on there right
so you know maybe you want to make it
i don't know 20
10 or 20. yeah you don't want to go too
crazy i mean and again you should
understand the market that you're
trading just don't you know willy-nilly
let's make it 10.
so you can see it's removed some of
those zeros in there right because it's
basically he's going from you know you
can still see the numbers on the side
here but it's basically 20 to 30 to 40
to 50 to 60 like that
even though it's still showing the scale
i mean that's just ninjatrader
that's one of the limitations
ninjatrader but it's now it's making a
little bit easier so
um
what is this
okay so here's the mnq
right it looks like a
normal chart right this is having queue
one minute where i have the tick
aggregation on
right so instead of having these big
sweeping bars up and down
it looks normal
okay now
granted you may be asking my oh why is
this candle look weird all right let's
have this little wick up here again
you're you're aggregating the ticks okay
so there might have been a trade you
know just outside of it but since you're
aggregating it i think this one i did by
eight ticks okay
um that's why you don't see that you
know maybe it was one contract up there
but it's really sort of putting it all
together now you this is a lot easier to
trade than
you know going back here 1350 this is a
one minute mnq chart
all right
if you're looking at this
right well heck man hello
what am i supposed to do with this bar
it doesn't even fit on my screen right
i actually have portrait i have 28 inch
monitors that i have turned portrait so
that i could see this
but do i really care that it's trading
you know this volume in here is
zero against seven zero against nine you
know seven against sixteen at these
individual price levels what's easier to
read that or this bar
right i see an area i'm still getting
good information right bullish prominent
point control another bullish power
point control market exhaustion multiple
imbalances
same move
but it's just looks manageable
now this is on a
futures chart again you're not going to
do this for every market most markets
you don't need to do this nasdaq
it's nice to do it on um if you're
trading crypto it's nice to do it on
if you don't have it turned on your
chart's going to look like this all
right especially on crypto right it'll
say you know where's bitcoin trading at
right now 38 whatever 900 but it's
actually trading 38 900 um spot
eight six four seven three two seven
right so it's just very messy it
easier right so it's shortening big
numbers right and it was specific to
cryptocurrency
but
it also can be used in
you're going to use it in all the other
contracts i have it turned on for
all my
stuff so you can see here right i can
see
it's you know the cumulative delta is
21.27
um you know the volume for this bar 73
k basically um
you can see like here these volumes
right in the in the 10 years um you know
that's 10.46 k 13.49 k because otherwise
it's going to be you need these big
numbers and it's just going to you know
basically keep this thing so open
um to see these
numbers it just makes it a little bit
easier
so again i'm going to send out the email
for users of existing users of order
flows trader the upgrade is free and if
you don't have the order flows trader
yet go to orderflows.com5.html
buddy i will create another video on
sort of this
what do you want to call it like the
strategies of using you know these tools
because it's one thing to have these
tools right
but you got to know how to use them
where to apply them
and you know sort of you know the the
different strategies so for example you
know for those of you that are still
sticking on um go back to crude oil or i
didn't go back i don't think i talked
about crude today
you know i love commodity markets right
and nothing's a greater commodity market
to trade than crude oil um
i wish i was watching crude oil in the
50s rather than the 90s i hate high gas
prices
but it's
just one of those things you know things
i hate high gas prices high taxes
there are certain
things well i tell you what
i'll just
show you just really quick
it's
uh
i'm not sure what
day sometimes you see these things and
they're just so
obvious
now in the night session now depending
on what you're looking at what i got on
on this one
i'm not sure
okay well this is sequencing um
i want to change that to
value areas
take off the sequencing
well for now i'll just
i'll just remove the sequencing one
i'll change that to fix i'll just remove
that and i'll go to value area so
again you know until tested
you got to change the box size the two
which is
unfortunately my programmers like i'm
sorry i
had to do that
to get it to work properly
on trending markets up and down you know
especially these markets sometimes you
see quick reversals
the way to catch them
if there was a quick reversal on friday
or actually
remember what market had a quick
reversal the other day
i'd like to look at night session there
but
um well this wasn't you didn't see the
quick reversal but this is what we call
cascading
here here here right you're looking for
the mark you know here so you already
got one two three four going in that
direction you know these ones that are
just small one area you know okay fine
it just happened that way it just
happened here you got that one big one
here one big one here one big one here
and then you start seeing the small one
you notice how the small one just came
right back up then the market fell over
right you're looking for
those moves and
sometimes you can get bigger zones big
zones like this
right from 80
you know basically a 40 cent zone
they hold pretty well
you don't see them a whole heck of a lot
but when you see them pay attention to
them
those big wide zones
i mean look at this right this is a zone
that came in from way earlier
market trader right down in there you
put in the primary point of control
and you rallied up
all right so if you just got a bid in
here somewhere up near the upper end of
this zone
for that test in there just like here
right you've got up here look at this
you got the zone from way earlier
came right up into there
25 area in here 25 26 you say you sell
it right at the bottom 23.
okay you know you got another zone in
here to hide behind okay so you're
getting short at 23.
even if you have a 10 tick stop up here
at 35 inside this next zone okay
you know you got that resistance already
right these are the value areas i'm
talking about here
you're getting short up here at 25.
all the way down well i got a zone down
here at 50.
okay
so when you start seeing
subsequent one two in a row
you know pay attention to those
you want to go in those directions
you know
it's just fascinating to see how these
markets often react well sometimes this
happens you get that zone trades right
back up
on the other side okay that's fine
that's that's trading you know that
happens
here you came down in here you got a
little bit of a rally up exhaustion
print and the market sold down
here
all right you got the zone
market rally up to where to that zone
right you know you had two in a row
right i just said buy the two in the
rows
but it traded right up into his own okay
the
you know in trading you want to often
trade in the path of least resistance
right and if you've got zones sticking
out
into you
um you know
you'd be careful like here you don't
really have any
of the bullish zones right you know
nothing being drawn out
so you got sort of clear sailing down
here right you're not running into any
potential support right
sold off nicely rallied back up into
that zone sold off you're still not
seeing any
bullish zones down here but anyway guys
i i could go on and on um i just hope
you guys
will find this software very useful
these changes and uh this upgrade rather
say changes um this upgrade very useful
i'm sure you will i i'm already
enjoying it that's why i
been literally working furiously to get
you that user guide out
this morning but after i finish this i'm
gonna get something to drink
have a brownie i'm going to send out
to existing users the link to upgrade it
you don't have to add in your user uh
sorry your license token
if you already have your license token
in on wordpress trader
it's fine now the question is do you
need to uninstall it you can to
uninstall the order flows three just go
to remove ninja script assembly
open it up
and give it a second to come up
and you can remove it
just scroll down to find it in here
order flows trader
just click that and click remove
takes about 30 seconds to remove
and then just
go on and
import the new one ninja script add-on
okay very simple
you don't need to shut down ninjatrader
then restart it then import it you
usually what i do i just remove the old
version then i import the new version
okay basically
as i throw out but you know it just
moves it to the trash folder
and then because because if you shut
down ninjatrader after removing it and
you open up ninjatrader doesn't have
your footprint on there
and then you gotta recreate your charts
from scratch again i think
if i remember right so anyway guys have
a great sunday
look for the email from me i'll be doing
another i'm not going to do another live
training on the strategies or methods of
how to trade these zones because you
know when you're dealing with zones
right there's so many different ways to
test it you know the important thing is
you stay bullish above bullish zones you
stay bearish below bearish zones
and
you know you
look for the mark you know another way
to trade them is you're looking for
um
the market to repair those areas
right and you're looking for them
depending on the markets and the zones
that you're drawing out look for the
areas to be retested
right like you would the value areas so
have a great sunday have a great
presidents day and again you know send
me an email if you've got any questions
on tuesday i'll be doing my regular
weekly live session with starting with
the
using the new software
so
use it for the next i said you know it's
a nice day sunday mondays markets are
open but nothing's who knows what's
going to happen biden says
russia is going to invade ukraine again
um who knows the crypto's been selling
off so
who knows we'll see with how the market
reacts uh tonight have a great weekend
everybody bye bye
you